hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to faction ater 2 now
there's another flash game and I know
I've been playing a lot of flash game
lately but this is a good one
and I'm actually good at the game which
means that I can show you how it's done
without worrying too much so the game is
basically a zombie infection simulator
but not like pandemic or anything like
that
what it is is you start the zombie
infection and then they of their own
volition will go out into the entire
world and then dominate and devastate
and kill everyone in the entire city
that you're in and then you go around
throughout the world trying to make as
many people go wrong and die because
that's how people die in my mind they go
broke okay and then you conquer the
world with your zombies so the first
city is Beijing because for some reason
a lot of zombie stories start in China
and I don't even know why if anyone's
read the Zombie Survival Guide handbook
it's a very interesting read but I
believe that as well as the zombie
apocalypse starting from patient zero
somewhere in China and I don't know what
they have against China I personally
don't have anything against China and
also there's this lady who has way too
much cleavage popping out of her shirt
anyway so you keep doing these over and
over and there's specific objectives for
these various levels and eventually I'll
get them good here but I haven't bought
any power-ups yet because I don't have
enough money to do so and you
continually level up over and over
through getting money and killing more
and more people and your zombies become
stronger and stronger and then you get
bonus zombies and then you get special
ultra mega zombies and then you get
special items and grenades that can blow
things up and your ideal objective is to
make sure that every city in the entire
world is completely destroyed
so do you get it you understand it's
really cool now also if you go back to a
city you'll realize that there are
objectives in this specific city kill
all in 40 seconds gather 150 golds kill
one people with support and then do it
with no support so if you do that the
entire city will never ever ever rise
from the ashes again
we'll be gone forever which is either
good or bad depending on disrespective
on zombies and zombie apocalypses in
general so that's my big spiel and now
I'm done because apparently this didn't
work
god dammit see that didn't do anything
because I don't we got one also it's
important to know that your your zombie
infection thing in the beginning has a
spray pattern originally it goes in a
cross diagonal plus sign and then it'll
eventually get more directions if that
sounds complicating you have no idea
what I'm talking about
you will in a second so before I do that
I'm gonna go to the next city so I can
at least get bonus gold from this one
cuz I stock but I do know what I'm doing
even though I suck then don't pay
attention to that nothing about that
makes sense
okay so now I'm at the upgrade screen
and I actually have enough to be able to
do these upgrades which make it slightly
better slightly better not a lot better
but slightly better and slightly better
as all we really need
there we go there we go it's getting
better that's more like it
yeah yeah yeah yeah alright so now we
can get Granada's which are important
because you want to be able to blow
everything up and once this is
completely destroyed kill one people its
support is literally all I need to do
pumping them look at that connector and
then you can put all that down and then
kill everybody anyway and then that's
the end of that wouldn't you get a
thousand bonus gold and that's how you
make a lot of progress in the game it
took me a while to realize that I didn't
even understand what the mechanics of it
was at the first time that I did that
but now things are better and now I can
move on to the next one and hopefully
you'd be able to do that bang Oh got it
got it killed everybody killed one with
grenade support that was another one
thing and that was it that was
everything I needed to do for that one
yeah do you see what I mean anyway this
game gets bigger and bigger as you go
throughout the entire world and kill
everybody in the end
our world and dominate everybody in
every sector of anything that's going on
here but then you get a little ahead of
yourselves and you don't need to worry
about that just yet ah Singapore I've
never been but eventually as you get
through the game you'll come across more
resilient humans ones that are police
officers and such and you want to make
sure that you get them first so that
they don't shoot your zombies and kill
them before they have a chance to infect
everybody which is actually kind of kind
of difficult to do because in the
beginning of the game your chance of
them getting infected after you bite
them and murder them is actually kind of
low so you need to do it over and over
again so that you get enough money so
that you're able to do what you need to
do and if I had more support I probably
could finish this level real quick oh
[ __ ] how long was that do ah sorry I
have no idea how long that was going on
what are the sides of the screen was cut
off it's not a problem in any of you
worry about but it's something that I
have to worry about as a professional
let player things go wrong all the time
and I have to make sure all the fires
are put out everything is dead okay so
the other objective in this one this is
where things get kind of crazy the maps
get bigger and bigger and bigger and
that means more money which is good but
it gets bigger and bigger and more
complicated to be able to kill everybody
involved so and that sounds really
morbid but you know it's a game it's a
video game and I just got a new support
thing called land mines or trap they're
literally land mines
see I don't know what malevolent force
is hovering above these cities causing
all of this carnage because zombies are
one thing but there's someone that's
throwing grenades and landmines from on
high and that sounds terrifying I have
no idea why that happens but it just is
what it is oh come on get him get him
get him no yes hahahahaha and it's
destroyed Singapore is gone sorry
everybody you thought I was bad starting
off nuking Detroit for a piece of cake
I'm gonna destroy the whole world
haha okay sorry I'm not sorry
just vote full declaration there was
another crisis and you guys didn't see
it but everything is fine this recording
is fine this let's play is fine you
don't need to panic and all in the
comments I know that happens a lot but
there's really no need this time anyway
it's gonna carry on like nothing where
are we now I didn't even look where we
were but I'm gonna assume that it's a
place with rich culture that I'm about
to devastate you know a lot of
historical history that happened you
know historical history is opposed
anything else I'm an idiot
who can't say words right if it wasn't
obvious I'm trying to speedrun this pipe
I sped run my death never mind I'm not
time to do anything now we're going to
Jakarta and again I have no idea where
that is oh well let's try well that's
not a good try because absolutely no one
got anywhere it's really it's actually
very difficult to make sure that you get
the larger Maps you should save for
later because they might be attractive
for money farming down the road but
initially they're not gonna be ideal so
you want to make sure that you get
through the smaller Maps first oh come
on she's over there
she said the girl oh you did it your
cart has been destroyed and one go I'm
devastating I am a menace to society
yeah then pasar if you're in any of
these cities give a shout-out in the
comments because I have no idea if I'm
infecting your own town okay well that
one pretty good for the first time mmm
Denpasar sorry Denpasar I just attacked
you didn't you do let's see
Tashkent if anybody is watching this
from Tashkent I'm sorry the capital of
Uzbekistan and the Tashkent oh well that
sounds important I probably shouldn't do
this then oh well it's already happening
see the good thing about this game is
that it's it's quite addicting and and
the thing about addicting games is that
they need to be fun and this one
actually is one that's fun even though
it doesn't feel like you're doing a
whole lot I mean again there's a lot of
things that could describe
my entire life but for as far as things
that don't feel like I'm doing a whole
lot it's fun in a way because it's a
unique perspective to this like game
that kind of plays itself if you know
what I mean
so it's it gives that sort of aspect to
it without too much brainpower but there
is some strategy dude because down the
road things get really really hard and
as you dive deeper into like Russia and
why not it becomes obscenely hard to get
everything done and there's the brute
who seems a lot like the tank from left
4 dead and you guys are gonna see that
all right
room key I'm coming back for you you're
ready for some of this you weren't
expecting this guy big giant man almost
oh come on so close
the big guy only lasts so long so he's
not there forever it would be nice
though I wouldn't be out here Kabul
I know Kabul ok sorry Kabul ha ha ha
ma'am there we go
that'll help I mean it won't help them
but it'll help me ah man so close only
three guys left damn it New Delhi oh
hello everyone from New Delhi sorry I
can't help it it's a game I have to oh
dammit why that no one
is this bull honkey see that the the
harder and harder gets based on more and
more soldiers and police officers and
people with guns that shoot you dead
which is good and then you can hit this
character called ill Kim Jong who is
actually very potent because he raises
zombies from corpses which makes
spreading the infection much much easier
and I'll get him in a little bit as soon
as I get through birth Hey that's what
Ross is from sorry Ross here goes Perth
although I speaking to him I don't know
if you'd be too upset about that head
hit there we go that's better I mean not
better still results in horrible zombie
apocalypse but better for me in terms of
getting my gold because that's all the
matters in this game whatever weird
world conquering person I am all I care
about is money and zombies oh I think
that's Ross down there he survived to
make more Mario maker levels the douche
Ok Go Go Go my zombo's go don't just
stand in a pile kill murderer maim there
we go I can actually destroy everything
before it actually gets done thanks boob
news lady
alright Adelaide I think I've heard of
Adelaide the cliffs of Adelaide no
that's not a thing is it that's that's
definitely not a thing
cliffs of Adelaide are never nothing
there we go hon take care of it all
destroyed I'm sorry Adelaide
it's a very pretty name I'm probably not
even pronouncing the name of your sitter
properly I'm sure Ross will beat me up
at the end of this episode now I can get
he'll kill you
ill Kim jong-il Kim Jong will be
released on Sydney of all places gonna
be slightly bigger one how bad have a
okay and then ill Kim Jong will be
spawned right in the zombie pit there so
that all the corpses will be turned into
zombo's aww almost there just little too
spread out not enough infectivity that's
the next thing that I need on this one I
did unlock Russia though so all my fans
in Russia you're about to be visited by
something's actually Russia is
incredibly hard to penetrate take that
whatever way you wanted it Stan Boone
I'm sure there's gonna be difficult it's
tiny city but it's still not gonna be
good in terms of
me destroy everything I bet he'll Kim
Jong get him the FBI is here well maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe yeah I did it
okay what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
visit all of these other cities because
I'm pretty sure it needs you to visit
the cities before they'll start
unlocking things for you plus I need a
lot more money so I'm gonna start
sleeping up the food I'm gonna start
sweeping up the cities and then I'll get
some more destruction later
all right Russia where are we starting
Oh God what what kind of name is that
Oh how am i a stupid American man
supposed to pronounce Krasnoyarsk is
that even remotely close probably not
too many soldiers here cut ass get me
out of here
gross me out nice is going down probably
maybe nope
all zombies killed while they don't f
around okay New Delhi I didn't even I
didn't even get close to doing anything
to do telling that stuff apparently Oh
lil Kim Jong you're not supposed to be
over there you're supposed to be where
all the dead zombo's are all right oh
wow
did okay Oh Oh delightful
Oh No No get her get her gah come on ah
come on you're so close what a load of
ass all right what about Brisbane Brent
Brisbane Brit Brisbane Brisbane up there
you are piled off in a corner not doing
anything important with your life I mean
your undead life you're on life
I'll get er dinner dinner yeah hey I'm
so proud of being a maniacal Overlord
that tries to destroy British been rude
rude before i in the episode I want to
conquer all of Australia that'll be like
my my end goal here just be nothing on
nothing i thing anything wrong with
Australia but just I know I have fans in
Australia what's the last one
Darwin Darwin is the last City but I'll
get to you in a second I gotta get to
Sydney Sydney you're going down
everybody in Sydney look out your window
this is zombie apocalypse happening oh
come on come on come on
yes no no get the kid ah the police
where did they come from
where did they go where did they come
from cotton-eye Joe okay now now we are
the winners no no we are do the good yes
please yes yes yes yes yes I'm very
happy about Sydney being destroyed what
do we have left let's see I think I kill
all in 35 seconds here I can do that yes
almost almost
yes yes yes yes I think that's all of
Australia
oh no wait there's one more there was
one more one more holdout City at Darwin
well Darwin you're not gonna be less
much longer cuz you're too densely
populated that's your problem here
and uh holy crap everyone died I didn't
even pay attention I was off in la-la
land now
now Darwin is going down and I'm putting
a stark with the grenades boom kaboom
okay there we go have you them zombies
sorry everybody
zombie attack right outside your windows
go go go yeah
there you and there we go in the end the
entirety of Australia has been destroyed
my apologies to all my fans in Austria
but this game is very fun totally free
you can check it out through a link in
the description below thank you
everybody so much for watching it if you
have fun games that you played online
lastly you want to see me play maybe
some more rayji ones if you'd like let
me know in the comments down below
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video this girl
doesn't make any sense
oh that's fat again